I've sort of played characters and that
have meant a lot to women and
specifically Jessica Jones so I get a
certain kind of person who wants to
connect and I I love that because it's
one thing to like just do an acting job
great love it but it's another thing
it's kind of so meaningful when you play
a character that really resonates with
women and and Men you know the way that
she has so I'm always thrilled when
people
um appreciate the work obviously anytime
someone comes up to you and says they
love your work you're like thank
you thank you so much obviously so I'm
happy to do it unless I'm like with my
little baby and like busy but okay just
not right now it's not a good time yeah
and you have to hold that boundary too
because I don't want my child's photo
you know I just I'm really private about
him he is number one
um but when I'm like out and about by
myself sure come up I'll take a
selfie right let's rock let's do it yeah
do your are your parents really proud of
you yeah yeah I think people are pretty
pretty shocked by it you know yeah like
does your mom still like every time you
do something go do they watch it all or
some like I don't know if they watch
Jessica Jones is really dark my dad
wouldn't watch that no and you warned
him I'm having sex in the first episode
I didn't even I I just knew it wasn't
right not to watch it it was okay that
they didn't watch it I just whatever